ونحييكم الى التفاصيل نفذت السلطات
الايرانيه الثانيه عمليه اعدام مرتبطه
بحركه الاحتجاجات المتواصله في البلاد منذ
حوالي ثلاثه اشهر وقال موقع ميزان اون
لاين اتبع للسلطات القضائيه الايرانيه قال
ان الشاب مجيد رضا
شنقا على الملا في مدينه مشهد شمال شرق
البلاد بعدما اودين بقتل عنصرين في القوه
الامنيه وبست تلفزيون الرسميه لقطات زعماء
انها تظهر المدانه وهو يطعن رجلينا حتى
الموت ثم يفروا هاربا وذكرت وكاله انباء
هارانا التابعه لمجموعه نشاطها في ايران
ان الشباب مجيد رضا لم يمنح فرصه للدفاع
عن نفسه هو حكم عليه دون الاستعانه بمحاما
ياتي هذا الاعدام اعدام جدا هو الاعدام
الثاني بعد محسن شكاري في تنفيذا سريعا
لاحكام الاعدام السطرات بحق المعتقلين في
المظاهرات التي ظهران قمعها ومن ثم اخمتها
[موسيقى]
مناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من رياض
الباحث في الشان الايراني صالح حميد اهلا
بك من لندن امين عام مركز مناهضه العنصريه
في ايران يوسف عزيزي اهلا بكم الكريمين
اسم حالي ان ابدا معك سيد عزيزي اييه امم
في الواقع عمليه اعدام ثانيه وصفها
المراقبون بالوحشيه
والعلنيه هي علنيه بالفعل وتبعها كثيرون
ماذا في فكر النظام لماذا يجاهر بهذا
الاعدام وهو الاعدام الثاني ولماذا يسرع
في تطبيق الاعدامات خاصه في فتره حساسه
يعيش النظام ويعيش داخل الايراني
تحياتي لكم واا في ضيفكم والي مشاهديكم
الكرام
النظام الايراني استخدم كل الادوات
والاساليب
لخانق هذه الانتفاضه الثوريه
التي بدات قبل نحو ثلاثه اشهر
استخدم اسلوب داعشي يعني جنه جماعه باسم
داعش في مدينه شيراز للهجوم على الزوار في
مرقد في احد المراه المراقد في مدينه
شيراز ولم ينجح لانه
المواطن الايراني في الواقع
ادرك هذا الاسلوب
وكذلك
من خامني الى
قائد الحرس الثوري الى الرئيس الايراني
الى رئيس ومرات
[موسيقى]
لكن لم ينسحب الناس من الشوارع
فكل
عزيزي وهذه المره بهذه الاعدامات بهذا
بهذه الطريقه من تنفيذ الاعدامات هل ينجح
في اخماد هذه الاحتجاجات تعتقد
والناس والتلاميذ والناس
طلعوا الى الشوارع
وقالوا كلمتهم اننا لا نخشى اعداماتك
الناس الليله خرجوا في طهران في عده مناطق
في طيران وكذلك رفضوا هذه
الاستفزازات التي يقوم بها النظام
الايراني وكذلك في مدينه شيراز
فهذا النظام في الواقع يواجه بالقتل
والموت شعار
المراه الحياه والحريه يعني هناك معسرين
معسكر معظم الشعوب الايرانيه ومعسكر
النظام الايراني الذي فقد كل وسائله من
جملتين الايديولوجيه الدينيه ولم يفلح في
هذه المباراه
بدنا نتحدث عن شقيان منفصلين تماما هكذا
تلخص المشهد ولكن سيد صالح كيف يفكر
النظام الايراني في تعاطي مع هذه
الاحتجاجات ومع هذه العقوبات خاصه انت
تعرف صالح بان النظام الايراني ليست
بالمره الاولى ولا الثانيه التي يعدم فيها
بطريقه علنيه في يوليو من اشهر قليله كانت
هناك كذلك همم تنفيذ للاعدام همم وكان
هناك تعذيب سبقات تنفيذ الاعدام هذا تم
كسر همم ايدي ارجل فك اسنان همم المتهم
كما اتهمته ايران وفيما بعد نفذ في حقه
همم الاعدام وبالتالي هنا السؤال هل
عمليات تنفيذ الاعدام هذا تاتي في اطار
همم عادي همم
تعاطي النظام الايراني مع مثل هكذا
الاتهامات او ان هناك فتره حساسه من
خلالها بدا نظام في تسريع وتيره تنفيذه
للاعدام للاع- اعدامات
الكريم استاذ يوسف همم الحقيقه يعني
النظام يهدف من خلال هذه الاعدامات
وهذا الاعدام الثاني ضد النشطاء المعتقلين
وعلى الملا الحقيقي لم يكن بالكامل
على تم في ساعات الفجر وهمم كانت همم
لازاله الظلام حسب الصور التي
نشرتها مواقع ايرانيه همم ويبدو انه
استدعى همم اسر القتلى من ميليشيات البسيج
وبعض انصار النظام يعني لم يكون على
الملابس معنى الذي يكون امام عامه الناس
لانه يخشى ان تتحول همم هذه التجمعات الى
الانتفاضه واحتجاجات ضده مثل ما حدثت في
مراسم تشيع العديد من قتلها هذه
الاحتجاجات لكن النظام يهدف بالطبع من
خلال تنفيذ هكذا اعدامات سواء على الملاء
او بشكل سري في السجون اولا الرعب في همم
صفوف الناس والمحتجين وهي سياسه يعني
يتبعها منذ عقود منذ ان استلم رجال الدين
السلطه في ايران عقبه همم الثوره عام 79
ثانيا يهدف الى ارسال رساله الى قواته
المنهاره في الواقع القوه الامنيه ومنشيئه
البسيج والحرس الثوري حسب التسريبات من
القاده الامنيين وفقما كشفت الوثائق التي
نشرها قراصنه على الانترنت من خلال اختراق
وكاله فارس لانه معنوياتهم انهارا ثلاثه
اشهر وهم يواجهون غضب الشارع وهذا الحراك
الثوري في كل انحاء ايران
تنفيذ الاعدامات هذه الرساله لقوات
الباسيج والشرطه الى اخره تتحدث عن انهيار
المعنويات ولكن هل هناك تراجع هل تسربت او
تسرب اي شيء يشير الى امكانيه تفكك تراجع
همم لهذه القوات
نعم كان هناك يعني تسجيل صوتي ضمن الوثائق
التي اشارنا اليها المسرب من الوكاله فارس
والقاده الامنيين يتحدثون عن انهيار في
المعنويات نقص في القوات
ان هذه العناصر القمعيه متعبه لانها لم
تنم ليالي عديده
بقائها في الشارع يكلفها كثيرا ماديا
ومعنويا وكانت هناك مطالبات ولذلك راينا
كيف ان المرشد علي خامني قبل حوالي 10
ايام اجتمع للشيعه البسيج وحاول رفع
معنوياتهم ايضا النظام يتبع هدف اخر وهو
ان يجر اا هذه المظاهرات السلميه نحو
العنف لانه بالطبع هو الاقوى في هذا
المجال ويريد ان يطبق نفس التجربه التي
طبقها في سوريا بالعازل للنظام السوري وفي
اليمن والعراق ولبنان والمناطق اخرى فلذلك
هو يعتقد انه هو الاقوى في هذا جانب وهمم
بشتى الاساليب في مقدماتها القمع ابدا مات
والاعتقالات ان يخمد هذه الانتفاض لكن
يحددها
صحيح هذا اعتقاده بانه سينجح في اخماد هذه
الاحتجاجات همم ردت الفعل عكسيه وتحدث منذ
قليل الاستاذ عزيزي عن مظاهرات في الواقع
نحن كنا تبعنا الاخبار هذا اليوم والعوازل
على العربيه همم مظاهرات في مشهد وفي
مختلف المناطق الايرانيه ولكن سيد عزيزي
هذا على المدى القصير هذه قد يقول البعضت
فعل انيه على تنفيذ الاعدام ولكن على مدى
المتوسط او البعيد قد ينهج المحتج
الايراني همم بمتابعه احتجاجات من جهه
وبمتابعه النظام الايراني ينفذ هكذا
اعدامات هل تعتقد بان النظام الايراني
سينجح على المدى المتوسط الى البعيد في
اخماد هذه الاحتجاجات او ان المعادله
تغيرت تماما في داخل الايراني هناك حسابات
اخرى هناك وضع اخر
غير تماما
لنفرض لنفرض ان النظام الايرانيه تمكن من
اخماد المظاهرات
لكن منذ ثلاثه اشهر حدث حدثت الثوره بل
البعض يصفها بالنهضه اي الرمسانس في عقول
الايرانيين هناك رفض لحكم رجال الدين
عندما
الجماهير يعني تهتف باننا لا نريد رجال
الدين يحكموننا عندما يقولون نريد دوله
مدنيه عندما يهتفون ضد الديكتاتور ضد
خامنه فمعناه ان هذه الناس هذه الشعوب في
ايران تريد حكومه علمانيه وطنيه
تبعد همم
الحكومه وما شابه ذلك
لهذا انا لا اتصور ان يستطيع النظام ان
يقضي على هذا هذا الحراك العظيم لكن اذا
افترضنا كما انتم همم قلتم هذا من جانب
ومن جانب اخر هنا في هذين المعسكرين همم
الذين يواجهون بعضهم ولا البعض معظم
الشعوب الايرانيه والنظام الايراني مع فئه
قليله معه النظام الايراني النظام هرم
معظم همم المسؤولين من خامني الى الاخرين
هم كبار السن يعني من 70 و75 وفوق فهذا
النظام لا يولد لا يولد شيئا جديدا لكن
انت جماهير مولده الجماهير ترونها 23 سنه
23 سنه
والبعض الاخر كذلك عينها على
مواقف الدوليه سيد صالح وباختصار انت
كرامته اليوم كانت هناك تصريحات
يشير فيها الى
نيه النظام ترهيب المحتاجين من خلال تنفيذ
هذه الاعدامات هل تعتقد بان هذه التص اول
مواقف الدوليه ان اشتدت قادره على تغيير
بوصله همم المعادله الداخليه في ايران
لها تاثير كبير يعني احد اسباب استمرار
هذه الاحتجاجات بثلاثه اشهر وبهذا الزخم
هو المواقف الدوليه بالطبع لن ترتقي الى
مستوى الدعم المباشر للمحتجين ولكن كان
الايرانيين دائما يخشون من مواقف او تداخل
خارجي لصالح النظام ضد شعب كما حدث في منذ
يعني 2009 الانتفاضه الخضراء ثم انتفاضات
2017 و 2018 ثم 2019 همم يعني اكتفت الدول
بالتمديد ولكن استمرت بالعلاقات مع النظام
الايراني وكان النظام يشعر بانه كل ما قتل
وقمع لن تتم محاسبته الان الوضع مختلف
راينا ان صوت همم الشعوب الايرانيه يسمع
لاول مره هناك تاثيرات كبيره
من قبل مجلس حقوق الانسان في الامم
المتحده ووقف المفاوضات التوجه نحو المزيد
من العقوبات ومحاسبه اركان النظام
الايراني بالتاكيد هذه ستؤثر معنويا
وسياسيا على الحراك الايراني في الداخل
وستزيد من زخم الاحتجاجات اذا ما عرف
الناس ان يد المجتمع الدولي رفعت عن هذا
النظام
الباحث في شان الايراني من الرياض وشكر
كذلك لضيفنا من لندن امين عامر العنصريه
في ايران يوسف عزيزي شكرا لكم
نتوقف مع فاصل المشاهدين ونعود من بعد
اهلنا متابع
عقوباتنا امريكيه على الصين بعد اقل من
يومين على اعلان واسطه رغبتها في اعاده
الدفئ للعلاقات هل وسط متناقضه ام متردده
[موسيقى]